Interviewer: What do you make of the European premier in Berlin? How does it look?
Martin: Well I think it looks fantastic. I love the big dragon, I love those Christmas lights,
Martin:  I love this *enormous* carpet, and I've always loved Berlin, so yeah, I'm happy.
Interviewer: And how's it to meet all your fellow cast members again?
Martin: Well, I've not really done it yet, because every time I go near someone, someone whisks me away.
Martin: I'm just waving at them from across the room, at the moment.
Martin: But we'll catch up in a minute.
Interviewer: What does it mean actually meeting the fans for you? How special is that?
Martin: It's very special. There are some very special people out there, and uh, they've been queueing up for a very long time.
Martin: Which we're very appreciative of, yeah.
Interviewer: Did having worked with Benedict Cumberbatch on Sherlock help you for this movie to work together again,
Interviewer: because you didn't really share a room together.
Martin: No, we didn't. Uh, I mean, it didn't hurt,  it was, it was nice, but it didn't really help.  In a way.
Martin:  I mean, it didn't hurt it, but it didn't help,
Martin: because I'm just imagining everything anyways, do you know what I mean?
Martin: So, it would have been perfect to do it with Ben, but we weren't able to, so you just gotta use your imagination.
Interviewer: Could you second-guess his performance maybe in a way?
Martin: No. Not really, no. No, I mean, no, because he's good!
Martin: So you know, so you can't expect too much.
Martin: Or you can't guess too much because he's going to surprise you.
Interviewer: Are you excited about Sherlock coming out?
Martin: No, I hate Sherlock. No, I can't stand it (laughs).
Interviewer: Because I was wondering, what can fans expect from the new season of Sherlock?  They're really excited I guess.
Martin: Are they?
Interviewer: They are, yeah.
Martin: Who's excited about Sherlock?
Martin: Do people watch it?
Interviewer: They do, yes!
Martin: No, of course I'm excited about it.  I think it's going to be great.
Martin: I've seen all three of them now. I think they're... they're fantastic!
Martin: They're fantastic. They were brilliant scripts, Ben does a great job again,
Martin: It's a thoroughly enjoyable job. It's one of my favorite jobs I've ever done. Or ever will do, yeah, we love doing it, yeah.